So when you've identified
a problem point in your app,
how do you go about figuring out
what the best solution is for that?
>> So the first thing to realize is that
to some extent honestly
there is no best solution.
There are lots of best solutions.
>> Mm.
>> and your job is just to find
one the fastest you possibly can.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So
the best way to do that is actually
through quantity rather than quality.
Don't necessarily focus on
finding the best solution,
just come up with the first thing
that you think might be better.
And then come up with the next ten
things that you think might be better.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
then make prototypes of all of those.
Again, we're going for fast and cheap.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So
that this is a really quick process.
Make ten prototypes, test them all.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And see which is better.
>> Okay.
>> Then do that three more times, or
four more times
>> Or five more times and
eventually you'll start to settle in and
really understand what people care about
and what's the best-
>> Mm-hm.
>> What really is valuable to them.
>> Right